let's see how you do we'll come to this
quadrant first what would you like a rap
about there were two you said snogging
lettuce for those either don't know
snogging is what the British people
called kissing because we thought that
sounds romantic let's make it sound
horrible
fancy a snog darling ooh
run away snogging what did you say
something about football club Liverpool
Football Club Liverpool Football Club
football is is what we call soccer and
Liverpool is where scary people live so
Liverpool Football Club snogging so far
so good
middle of the room what you want to rap
about you said Jeremy Clarkson you said
the Salem witch trials I like that
snogging Liverpool Football Club
Jeremy Clarkson the Salem witch trials
segment over here well okay what
happened there was someone went beat
someone went crikey and someone went the
Holocaust which gosh that escalated
quickly
and so we're obviously gonna discount
one of those for obvious reasons because
I have many traumatic memories of going
to the beach no no someone said crikey I
like that
crikey crikey crikey Jeremy Clarkson
Salem Witch Trials snogging and
Liverpool Football Club okay that'll do
cool lovely people at immersive Beach
this is what we're gonna do we're gonna
do a freestyle rap made up entirely on
the spot nothing is written nothing is
rehearsed let's roll that B let's see
how we do
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm excited and you are as well clearly
yeah take that while away the time come
to Salem you can enter this trial of
mine which which will it be
never make a mistake if they float or
sink I still tie them to the stake I'll
be lad in a mop I'm gonna flame in the
dark I will burn now which lashes Joan
of Arc she was just 14 when they did it
to her people in the Devo France they
were like we don't go you been Sam by
God but I say again let me move it to
America and in Salem people turned
against their neighbor the end they
would be they were pointing fingers of
the person make a good deed that's the
term they use they're back in their life
I wanna move on here and my mother's
midwife when I was delivered coming out
of her womb
they said crikey I must assume this
British boys so I'll say that phrasing
in Australian they like to go oh it's a
praise they're like crikey mate I'm
gonna tell you the truth you call that
or not oh bloody hell's truth there's a
kangaroo and if you invite me round to
your house party or say crikey if
someone pushes the play back after their
second course and says yeah wrap-up of
the Holocaust and everyone said no we
won't go there
that would just kind of sour the move in
here it wouldn't be good yeah you take a
bunch of fires like Jeremy Clarkson
Denny's unwise if you don't know who he
is he's a wanker if you've never heard
of him but I would thank you we like to
drive fast cars there again round the
track making laps and he's on Amberson
cuz the BBC fired him for misconduct
every time he goes on TV self-destructs
he's the worst guy I'll tell you why
because he's far too old to wear that
tight denim jacket that he does I see
you on the promo shot let me talk about
some guys it's a track suit toss
Muhammad Salla he looks so cute every
time he gets the ball
people are likes you he's the leading
scorer in the Premier League
apart from sorry your money I believe
they he'll succeed they play for
Liverpool FC I know it's confusing in
the Premier League they will be losing
the title to Manchester say is gonna
happen next week and it won't be pretty
people over there saying we have not got
belief in that yeah bigger Kenny
Dalglish he's an all player for that
team no one in here knows him
Wow I'm keen to do the last thing remind
me what the word you gave was yeah we
got it going yeah this is the greys I
was doing it when I was a lumberjack in
logging I walk up to a guy in the plaid
shirt guest knocking I stay in look at
you I'm so uncertain but I like
you you're a big timber man not Tim
Burton I went in for a French attracted
to this guy cuz he's looking hench eyes
deep blue like the Marianas Trench
Liverpool won't do well if no silos on
the bench
[Applause]